The Washington Post reports that North
Korea appears to be building new
ballistic missiles unnamed US officials
tell the Post that spy satellites have
detected activity at a factory outside
Pyongyang that produced long-range
missiles as recently as July 7th
now that is less than a month after
President Trump summit meeting with
leader Kim jong-un and mr. Trump's tweet
declaring that North Korea was no longer
a nuclear threat fast-moving wildfires
threaten more than 14,000 homes and
other buildings in Northern California
the so-called mendocino complex fires
are burning in rugged terrain about 90
miles north of San Francisco one fire
reportedly got within a mile of the city
of Lakeport yesterday before
firefighters pushed it back there are
now 17 large fires burning across
California they've killed at least eight
people
Mireya Villarreal is in Ukiah near the
mendocino complex fires good morning
good morning these fires are responsible
for destroying seven homes and now fire
officials are saying they could threaten
up to 10,000 structures the conditions
right now are dry hot and windy at times
so these firefighters they are trying to
keep the flames from moving from the
hills to any of these homes the
mendocino complex fires are burning
through rugged terrain in the hills of
Lake County moving quickly enough to
threaten highly populated towns nearby
cell phone video captured the moment
drivers had to turn around on a main
highway when the road was blocked by
planes what is it about this area that's
so susceptible you could see how thick
this vegetation is if there's a fire
that comes into an area like this you
can't put personnel in here the aircraft
the helicopters that are working this
fire that is the best approach to fight
a fire like this with the winds picking
up you can actually see there are flames
that are building up near a lot of these
homes that's why crews have come into
this area they are laying down hoses and
building lines to try and protect
structures just like this one this is
the view of a qyz based over the weekend
many families had to pack up twice in
the past two days with the first shelter
they went to had to be evacuated itself
on Monday I didn't think it was going to
be like that I thought we were just
going to go and stay
still not everyone is complying with the
mandatory evacuation orders once areia
says he's staying put even though he saw
his neighbor's field catch fire your
life could be in jeopardy if my life is
in jeopardy I'm not going to risk it for
material things but as long as I can
defend it I will this is all I got this
is all I got the strain of battling
these blazes is taking a toll on
firefighters one fire official I spoke
with say it's not only a physical but a
mental drain as well a lot of these guys
are putting in long strenuous hours and
on top of all that they're away from
their family and friends for long
periods of time
alex is dramatic footage Mireia thank
you